The answer is no. I mean, of course you can do it, but it'll give you really bad data.
The reason is the data is paired.
These two guesses correspond to each other.
The same person guessed 78 over here and 80 over here.
The same is true with the next two guesses.
If we just remove the lowest quartiles in the first list and the second list,
we'll remove different elements, and the surviving elements don't fit together,
and we can't really run regression anymore.
We have to keep that correspondence alive.
I removed all the data points where either of the two components
would guess a value under 50.
If it said 0 or 1 over here, I'd remove the entire data point in both lists.
The same is true for weights over 120.
I figure I really don't look like a 200 kg guy or like a 1,000 kg person.
I figured 120 is fine, but beyond 120 is really not a reasonable guess.
The reason why I use these brackets is I really have to remove data pairs together.
That was the easiest way for me to remove outliers.
Let's look at the data again.